Hey, what's up guys we are here at the park today. We're here with Devin Graham
Hey guys long time no see and Shawn Duras. [oh], hey long time no see
Happy birthday bud high five so we are back here with the sky Blaster slingshots
And we have some of these little novelty balloons
You may have seen these floating around the stores these are like bunch of balloons or battle balloons or balloon blasters they go by like
A million different names, but do they actually work, I don't know but that's what we're gonna figure out
So here's the deal last year when I made these things I actually tried filling these up
And I didn't really have much luck or success the idea is you attach these things to your hose you can just turn them on
The balloons will fill themselves up, and when they're big enough. They'll just drop off automatically kind of like fruit dropping from a tree
Yeah, sounds good, and then they're good to throw right, but what I found in my experimenting was when you throw them
They don't really pop
They're like super hard balloons and so if you throw them or shoot them at somebody they'll leave welts all over your body
This is gonna be fun because we have lots of friends coming over
We have What's Inside, Devin Supertramp a whole bunch of friends are coming over, so we're gonna have a water balloon fight
[Grant]:We're gonna shoot them at Devin cuz he's...[Shawn]: I like that. I think Devin's the new Target.[Devin]: I am the guinea pig for today.
[Shawn]:Yeah, I like that one should be easy.[Grant]: You see after that Marshmallow blasting session...[Devin]: I still have welts all over my body.
Yeah, test number one pink balloons. Hopefully this works there is no app for pink first Grant
Well Cause Devin handed it.
Oh its a pretty color.
Okay
What I think we should do is actually fill this bucket up with water
So when the balloons drop they have a soft..[Shawn]: Oh. got it got it got it [Grant]: this is really hot right now
And I'm not sure how they will affect the performance.[Shawn]: It's okay though. You're hot too ..water cannon
Where's Devin? Oh shoot sorry. I didn't know you were all sorry..[Devin]: except that it is your camera ...[Shawn]:that Camera's seen much worse
So these are the balloons that I used last year. I got him out of  Walmart
They are like Red blue and green different balloons
And I didn't have much luck with these let's let's try them this year and see if they've made [any] improvements
the
experience
I had before is some of them wouldn't blow up at all the other ones that did blow up and get big they would like
Leak out [alright]
Sweet these already look different than they did last year because they used to be these like really cheap pieces of plastic
This is awesome. No, I got about to go play Pokemon
Go, you should just let them drop off or do you think we should like let them drop?
Like hold them up here. Yeah
Like my little babies
So it's Pokemon go look at all these three pokemons
I just got yeah honestly this is a much better experience than it was last time
Hey, they actually all look pretty even surprisingly yeah, yeah, they're filled to a pretty good size. I'm actually really impressed
I wasn't expecting that to happen. I was expecting like little baby dinky ones. [Shawn]:Whats up Lincoln?
That's where we're going right there these are gonna hurt
"They will"?Yeah, whoo all right that actually worked, ten paces. Let's do. This are you serious? Yeah, okay? So eight nine five
as if it just bounces right off yeah
Back shot ten points so all of mine bounced off of you
I don't know if you know I mean that's cuz you just got thrown with a heart now. I don't know if you noticed oh
That was a long one
That one I get down. That was a cheap shot. I'm not even kidding
You high-five totally like a bow hold like a bow and arrow like this is okay. "yeah"
I meant to hit Sean
It's been a couple of minutes and some of these are actually losing, mass
so I think they do have a shelf life like if you squeeze it hard enough that thing will probably even pop up look at
thats how you do it.
You can make little squirt guns out of them what?
Pick on someone your own size.[Grant]: what happened to you, did you just get dunked? Yep
Definitely, definitely if you fill up your water balloons in the water it relieves enough pressure
And they can get a lot bigger, and it seems to break a lot easier as well
So I don't know if the [name-brand] makes a difference, but we'll find out here
You are going down for that!  look at that. He just completely assaulted me. This is actually the kind of cap
I was expecting cuz that's what we had last year. Oh
Shawn Duras is about to feel the wrath. This is how it works [see] little launch pouch made out of duct tape
Balloon fits right in there like so lock it. Oh
Direct hit, how do I feel how about feel that was that was pain by with my arm?
And it still hurt these resistance bands are actually quite quite strong in fact this guy blaster, slingshot
I made here this prototype was actually my wife's workout band if I [workout]
I went down to [her] exercise room and chopped that up into a prototype. So thank you for letting me do that
I made a couple slight modifications from my video. You can see I
Middle pieces to three inches which makes a little more compact, and I [used] some 45 degrees here on the back
What that does it just gives you a little bit cooler look as that rests against your forearm there
And this one is painted with red Spray paint, but you can use duct tape as well
I got some of this carbon [fiber] duct tape and you [can] see actually does just as nice of jobs wait
What are we doing another round? Yeah, but we have to use
How about no shooting in the face?
Lincoln, check this out when the balloons are about the size that you want all you have to do is give them a quick tug
Upward whoop, they're all come off. How big do they actually get before they fall off from the runway?
It looks like white fruit growing on a tree doesn't it?
Can feel them get ready to drop there you go? Yeah!
Game on let's do this. Oh my turn
Hello
The smaller the balloons are the better
They're gonna work with the slingshots cuz they're a little more resilient these bigger ones kind of a little bit Trickier. Let's get Lincoln. Oh
Pink packs a little more punch ain't bad the trail
Okay, so our experience actually hasn't been too bad. It seems like probably nine out of ten balloons will fill up
They do hurt like crazy though. I got hit on the shoulder blade by Lincoln.Where did he go that little stinker
So the bigger the balloons are the easier they pop which is a good thing if you're having water fight
But if you want to shoot them out of the slingshot smaller is probably better. Let's see how high we can go with this oh
You just got water we go. Oh
that freaking rocks
So these things have gone insanely viral. It seems like anybody who makes a video about them racks up millions of views
And they're really expensive and I want you to know what you're getting for your money
Are they worth 10 bucks 10, 10 bucks for I'd pay good 750 for those 750
I paid 750 right there you go guys 750 we've confined for 750
That's about what they're worth, but cleanups a bit of a pain
I'm not sure if these things are biodegradable or not
But we are over here and clean them up just in case and now there's a party happening over here
Shonduras is 29th birthday guys and of course I get the  of random to come to my birthday party
Slip and slide every base is a pool check this out if you want to see the [waterslide] Kick ball
I'm totally getting in on this. We're gonna go over to the Shawn duras, okay?
Yeah, come on over we have fun and Graham's gonna play off